all right let's take a little bit of a
visit to fantasyland today donald
trump's former press secretary kaylee
mcinanny appeared on fox news last night
and this is a really instructive clip in
revisionist history and how quickly the
failed administration is trying to
completely rewrite the past and if you
don't uh if you're not aware of it if
you don't say no we're not going to let
you do that they will gaslight you into
completely forgetting about what went
down for four years before joe biden was
sworn in as president in january of this
year kaylee mcinanni appeared on fox to
talk about how chaotic the biden
administration is the context is
afghanistan as well as joe biden's
diminishing approval rating we've talked
about the diminishing approval rating
with trump things were different but
typically presidents come into office
with higher approval ratings and they
sort of diminish over time and we've
talked about the dynamics of why
kaylee says during trump's presidency
you didn't have crisis after crisis
things weren't chaotic
things were calm
what
and she's able somehow to say it with a
straight face let's take a look at the
clip right we are eight months into a
biden presidency jesse wrap your head
around that we still have three years
and four months left look when president
trump was president you didn't see
crisis after crisis you just didn't see
it can you imagine going on national tv
and saying that with a straight face so
for starters half a million dead from
covid under trump as if it's no big deal
it's the flu open everything no masks
it's a democratic hoax
and then of course i mean i don't have
an hour but the ukraine scandal the
north korean failure the migrant border
crisis attacking reporters and the
institution of a free press
using a sharpie to change a hurricane
map merely to make himself look better
going to puerto rico after a hurricane
not knowing puerto ricans or americans
and then tossing rolls of paper towels
like their basketballs
telling people in his administration to
slow down testing because too much
coveted testing is making him look bad
inciting a riot on january 6th claiming
that an election was stolen and trying
to actually stay in power despite the
fact that he lost
i would need an hour to go through the
full list of crisis a day scandal a day
trump presidency review
does kaylee think we slept through
trump's entire presidency or that we
have collective amnesia and then also
hilariously or just horrifyingly like
this is just the bottom of the barrel
kaylee mcinanny actually says
imagine if joe biden had been in charge
when the virus hit i i shudder to think
about what kovid would have been like
under joe biden we've seen afghanistan
blow up crime in the streets you named
it all what would kovat have been like
because i was in the white house when it
was pretty scary times so there is just
so much there and you know first of all
it's interesting how she admits
it was scary
it was scary times
when coveted hit
the entire time she was in the white
house and trump was president neither
she nor trump admitted that it was scary
times she's admitting it now in order to
say it would have been too scary
for joe biden to handle but at the time
it was
this is all fine
uh it'll be gone by april
freedom and liberty will be opened by
easter 15 cases will soon be zero it's
like the flu on and on now though it was
so scary joe biden never could have
handled it but most importantly
trump's handling of coronavirus was one
of the worst in the world by the numbers
during that first year
when trump was in charge we scaled up
our testing
so slowly that we were constantly behind
the curve
trump wanted testing slowed down he
wouldn't wear a mask he wouldn't tell
people to wear masks he played coy with
the whole freedom and liberty thing and
attacked governors that were actually
taking the virus seriously and putting
in place all sorts of different measures
and kaylee mcinanny has the audacity to
come in now
and say imagine if biden had been
president well we'd have had fewer dead
if joe biden had been president wouldn't
be zero of course the virus has ravaged
most countries to some degree
but we would have been far far better
off and so it's important to prevent
them from rewriting history it's
important not to allow them to tell us a
story that is completely divorced from
reality and we must remember that the
trump covet response was a historic
failure some might even even say it was
an historic failure
it's more of a grammatical question than
a historical one but we have to ensure
that uh it's not rewritten and um
unfortunately
you know there's just
there's just a reality that political
memories are short even now when we're
seeing joe biden's approval rating
diminish
at least in part because of what has
been a successful campaign to discredit
and attack joe biden's withdrawal from
afghanistan which i am completely in
favor of and consider one of his
major accomplishments getting us out of
a 20-year quagmire in afghanistan talked
about it earlier and earlier this week
so i won't go into it again now
they are um
there's the idea of wow what could this
really hurt democrats in 2022 i kind of
think it won't
number one because
it's not really the democrats that are
up for re-election it's joe biden and
because political memories really are
short so it's important to remember that
but still we shouldn't allow them to
rewrite history and of course fox news
which
that's one other thing actually i think
is important to mention
we've talked anecdotally over the last
three four weeks oh look fox isn't doing
as much anti-vaxx propaganda anymore fox
news is sometimes telling the truth
about
the safety of the vaccine or whatever
for the most part and in particular the
nighttime shows although it's on the
daytime shows as well
a fox news is still hosting
promulgating
signal boosting and allowing
really really aggressive propaganda
disinformation misinformation and the
rewriting of history and last night's
kaylee mcinanny appearance uh is just
more more of the same
do not forget that one of the best ways
to support the david pakman show is by
supporting our awesome sponsors and
today one of those sponsors is sheath
underwear
the weather is warming up it's hotter
it's stickier out there and
unfortunately for many of us that comes
with a lot of sticking and rubbing and
chafing with traditional underwear
that is what sheath underwear has solved
sheath has developed unique boxer briefs
with multiple ergonomic compartments in
the front preventing skin on skin
contact that means everything stays
separate dry cool and comfortable with
sheath underwear there is no more
sweating no more chafing no more
readjusting it's great sheath underwear
is giving the david pakman show audience
20 off when you go to sheath underwear
dot com slash pacman and use the promo
code pacman give sheath underwear a try
my experience has been great i believe
yours will be as well you can find the
link underneath this video and do not
forget to use that promo code pacman for
20 off